foreign
Boise and talk to the great Stephen
what's up Steven in Boise
hey how's it going John thanks for
taking my call you got it man we're
partying how about you
oh you know just just living the dream
that's so great like the last three or
four shows the first caller always says
I'm living the dream and that almost
always means for sure not living any
sort of dream at all right maybe a
nightmare but what's up man
so my question today is
I kind of feel like I'm realizing I tend
towards codependency and kind of people
pleasing in my life and I've kind of
tracked at kind of seeing how my dad
example that for me he's pretty much
been kind of in a codependent type of
marriage really just kind of appeases
his way through through his marriage
kind of not standing up for you know
what he thinks and stuff just trying to
not rock the boat
um just just kind of slide on by and
then you know here here I come up
through life
and go into the life of adulthood and
with friendships and work and especially
like my marriage I kind of find myself
really kind of doing the same thing just
kind of not being the real me just kind
of putting on in front of people what I
want them to see and not really you know
communicating well because I'm just
trying to I kind of just appeasing my
way through life I feel hmm and have you
found yourself that how old are you now
I'm 36. okay 36. so perfect so have you
found in the last four or five years
it's usually running somebody turns
30-ish
um and then on through 35
you have found that the very thing you
are working against which is people
leaving you or abandoning you or getting
frustrated by you
are now leaving you and frustrated by
you and kind of moving on with their
lives
yeah a little bit or kind of you know
getting to where it's it's more thing
like that's kind of on the verge of
being that as well
um there have been a couple like that
yeah so what happened that precipitated
this call like something usually
happened and you're like dude I got I've
got to think of another way of doing
life what happened
well really it kind of came down to in
my marriage my wife is just kind of like
hey you know man you gotta you gotta
start you gotta stop being frozen in
place and you know you got to start you
just got to start you know
I haven't have a direction and not just
worrying about you know what others
think or even even more so I guess you
know maybe on her part as well and again
I'm thinking okay if I go and and say
hey this is this is what I'm thinking so
I want to do well maybe it doesn't
really align with hers I know he's had a
couple disagreements on a thing where
we've we've she has an opinion one way I
have an opinion the other way and in the
end I just kind of go and after a while
like I don't want the fight I don't I
don't want to keep going around around
this so sure fine we'll just kind of do
do what you want to do and then she can
see well hey he's not really
on board with this and so we just kind
of get stuck kind of in that cycle and
that Loop going around and around kind
of the same thing and nothing really
gets resolved because I don't want the
fight and she wants it resolved and I I
don't I don't want to upset her because
I want to go this way and it just yeah I
can't go around around circles
so
just imagine
what happens if you dug your heels in
I don't I'm talking about something
minor I don't want to eat at that
restaurant
I've been thinking about it all day I
don't want to eat there it's gross I
won't eat here
and she gets so mad she says well fine
I'm going by myself and she leaves you
at home that night and you are pissed
and she is so mad
is She Gonna Leave You is she gonna
divorce you over that
no not over that would you divorce her
no so what's the thing you're so worried
about
I guess you know that it's that
that I I just want to be
I guess
I don't I don't like to be in Conflict I
just don't like the feeling of the
conflict I guess so I'd rather just say
but you also don't like the life that
you've created which is everybody like
what you think and dream about and
really feel deeply nobody cares because
you have squashed that so hard
right you kind of bound yourself up
like damned if you do damned if you
don't right right yeah yeah
oh man was your mom abusive to your dad
um very I say emotionally pretty
emotionally
um there's there was even a couple times
she even threw out the um the threat of
a suicide to get him to do what she
wanted him to do okay
um did that roll over to you too
so sometimes I can say abusive and
people think like hitting with sticks
and like physical abuse
um in in the psychological world we talk
about position powers and there's the
one up position which is usually not
always but usually men they Flex they
stay they Lord outright they're big and
they lean over they hit they throw
and there's often it's often a feminine
position not again not always but it's
the one down position which is the well
I guess I just won't eat then y'all just
go do your thing and I won't eat and or
the um well if you weren't so stupid
then I guess this wouldn't have happened
so I guess I'll just I'll just do it all
um and either one of those is an
absolute power play right and to get
what you want
um and both of them I think are
Insidious in their own ways but which
one did your mom use
uh she can't she used the um I found it
kind of the the second one
um and and she would also and she would
kind of utilize
um you know silent treatments very well
I mean as as I kind of learned she would
have they would have some issue and she
would just you know transform into this
look like she was you know 40 years
older than she was just moping around
for three days and then suddenly
suddenly you know four days later uh the
sun comes up bright and shiny and she's
all and everything's fine and cool you
think until the next thing comes along
as a kid uh yeah yeah she did that to me
and I I kind of first became aware of
that kind of as a teenager there was one
instance where I kind of had had dropped
the ball on something and instead of you
know her saying hey you know you dropped
the ball in the sun she's like hey you
you upset me you ruined my day and kind
of you know put it back upon herself and
and then you know went to the kind of
the same motions
so I'll catch some Flack for this and I
don't care
I think parents who utilize the silent
treatment on their children that's
abusive
what it's doing is it's taking it's
severing the relationship between the
parent and a child
enforcing the child to rebuild that
connection and that is not a skill or a
task a child can do outside of just any
sort of pleasing Behavior
right there's no way a child can fix
that
can um be restorative because the power
Dynamic is so wonky so anytime a parent
utilizes the silent treatment especially
on the back of what you got which is you
failed me
so I feel this way and it's your fault
12 year old 14 year old 16 year old
nine-year-old and so I'm cutting off my
relationship your relationship with your
mother now just imagine like a football
coach doing that or a soccer coach
hey uh you made me mad so I am cutting
off the relationship with your mom for
three days
that person would go to jail I can't do
that
but inside houses it happens all the
time and so we're really I mean you and
I could talk for a couple hours and so
we're really condensing your life into
just a few minutes but extrapolate that
out here it doesn't surprise me that at
the greatest gift you feel in your body
is everything above the water is still
because
any sort of this any sort of
dysregulation any sort of um trying to
think of it any sort of fires in the
house
got you cut off from Mom you watched
your weak father just get beat down and
you guys were left trying to control Ma
how mom felt and that's no kid's job
okay and now you got a wife
that is somewhat begging you will you
please tell me what you want
I don't want to be married to us I can't
anchor into a sponge that will just is
just gushing through life and we'll do
whatever their boss says whatever their
stupid friend says whatever dumb
neighbor says whatever little college
roommate says I want somebody who I can
anchor into and
who can anchor into me we can do this
thing together
so she's asking you for that why are you
scared to put that out there
yeah I guess like I said before is it's
I I have those feelings of okay I just
don't want
people upset at me or I just don't want
the conflict that I would just I would
just rather I'd rather just hide under a
rock than do up a conflict and then
um and then you can kind of I guess
those those same feelings of being a kid
kind of again where you know I was
pretty much train hey just just just
just make Mom happy just just kind of
say what she wants even if you don't
even if you don't feel that's what you
really want just do that and your life
will will go you know you'll be able to
slide on by there you go and what I
don't want for your marriage is either
of you to slide on by
I want you all to tangle and co-create
something magic and good for you you
married somebody that's not your Mom it
sounds like
sounds like you married somebody that
really wants you involved in this thing
right how long you've been married
uh 14 years how many kids you got
five God Almighty five kids okay so is
she watching this thing recreate itself
yeah or she feels like she's got to make
every decision for every person all the
time
very parent here
and does she feel like she is
um has a sixth kid in you
I think so yeah she's she's sometimes I
I know she's really kind of said that
out loud but this kind of in some of the
some of the actions and things said like
it kind of sense that
do you also feel this this fear of
conflict with your kids too
I guess yeah probably a little bit
um
where we haven't had like any like major
stuff the other the oldest is 12 but so
she's getting to the point where we're
probably going to be hitting more you
know she comes into her own more more
conflict and stuff and that I guess that
kind of scares me a little bit all right
so
the idea of codependency
is I value other people's lives more
than my own
okay
if we drilled and I'm gonna let them do
whatever they want whenever they want
however they want
because at the end of the day I can't
imagine my life without that
relationship my life ends my oxygen runs
out without this relationship so I'll
let him drink I'll let him abuse me I'll
let them do whatever they want
I don't necessarily hear that with you
okay what I hear with you is somebody
who is very conflict avoidant
and in a weird way you may not even
really care kind of like what my wife
was asking me about my wedding like
it took us a minute like for her to
understand like no I'm for real I just
want to marry you I I mean I don't I
literally don't have an opinion on where
we eat what we don't do I want this kind
of music and she's like cool do that so
sometimes there's some negotiation there
here's what you've got to do moving
forward number one you've got to decide
I'm breaking the cycle that I grew up
with
and that means you have to acknowledge I
don't have a set of skills that I'm
gonna have to get and then I'm gonna
have to practice those skills you are
Shaquille O'Neal back in the day
I can't make a free throw that means
I've got to practice free throws I can
dunk the basketball nobody can stop me
in the paint but I can't make a free
throw I've got to practice free throws
that's what you're gonna have to do and
what that means is you're gonna have to
practice saying out loud I want this I
need this
we're going to go eat here
's my boundaries on X and Y and Z
whatever
and then you're gonna have to practice
feeling super uncomfortable
and letting that feeling just roll
through you and probably come up with
some sort of language with your wife and
say honey you're about to
um
get a whole new husband but it's going
to take me some I'm gonna have to I'm
gonna have to work to get there will you
help me
and she'll say oh my God it'd be amazing
and say I know you probably don't think
it's super hot to hook up with your
another sixth son so I'm gonna become
your husband
um what do you need
and let her tell you here's what I need
and then you have the courage and the
strength to say here's what I need
and then y'all can start working on
meeting each other's needs and you're
gonna what you're gonna find is the
whole thing lifts up it's just gonna
take some time because you are literally
taken 35 years of life and trying to
control all delete it in in in many in
many ways
and also by the way you don't have to
lose your compassion and you're kind of
just chill attitude towards life
that can still be a part of who you are
you're not just going to turn into like
Jocko and be like all right let's go run
50 miles it's probably not gonna happen
but you can have some opinions and you
can't put your foot down and your wife
can put her foot down and that's when
the real fun begins but if you both put
your foot down in service of this
incredible marriage that we get to
decide what it looks like in this life
we're building for our five kids
um then those those disagreements are
absolutely worth it
it's going to navigate how it looks for
me I'll tell you for me and my wife
um we don't do good with spur with
um it's not spur of the moment but with
flash fights the thing comes up and I
say this and she says that we both know
we're gonna put a pin in this and talk
about it later because we're not going
to solve it right then because her her
things kick in my things kick in and all
of a sudden it's we're not we're
fighting we are not trying to solve a
problem but then we loop back in a day
at the end of that day and 30 minutes
later depending on what we're talking
about or a week later man we can solve
that thing no problem and I like hearing
what she has to say about it and I like
feeling uncomfortable and be like ah I
really thought this but I think but dude
I love that stuff and like you
um take some practice
take some practice I think you're
heading the right way I think that let's
do this let's start this exercise with
this I want you to sit down today by
yourself
and write down in your marriage here's
four or five things I really really need
here's four or five things I really want
for me and my wife I want for me I want
for my kids
and then I want you to take your wife
out and read those out loud and tell her
this is making me nervous and
uncomfortable but I'm committed to
changing this I want to give you
something concrete to Anchor into
and then we're gonna practice getting
there
and hear hers too because she's got a
she's got a role to play here and a
role's not your mama
her role is your wife your partner your
co-creator
person that's building this life with
you you got it brother thank you for uh
being brave and give me a shout